well it has proved to be a pretty busy
day over at the las vegas convention
center as more and more people become
eligible to get their vaccine kristen
that's right well thursday the health
district added food service and
hospitality workers to that list
joe muller joins us live from the
convention center with more joe
christian with new eligible groups
people were doing what they could to
get an appointment right now this
parking lot outside the las vegas
convention center is empty but earlier
today it was a completely different
story take a look at this video from
earlier
people say it took them 20 minutes just
to get into the parking lot
a woman we spoke with tells me a worker
told her there were 7
000 appointments today so it was busy
people were in and out still in about an
hour's time
hospitality and food service workers
just became eligible as of yesterday
afternoon
so that is why it was busy ashley kelly
works at the bellagio
she and many co-workers are glad to
finally be eligible
we've been waiting for this a long time
one of my old bosses
actually sent me the email said we can
start getting it
as of today so i booked it last night
and came this morning
some new information today from the
state kobut response team the health
district is working with pharmacies to
open up eligibility next week to people
55 and older with underlying health
conditions
disabilities and homeless individuals
details on when exactly are still to
come
a plan is also in the works to have one
vaccine clinic to operate more hours to
accommodate
people working overnights in the
hospitality industry now state officials
say opening this up to this next group
is
vital for our economy especially here in
las vegas that woman we spoke to earlier
says she is very happy to get her first
shot before
the capacity changes next week reporting
live at the convention center this
evening joe mohler 8 news now